DC Comics and said that in his first
inaugural address as our nation's 16th
president so if you'll please have your
tickets ready we can begin the toy wait
what the was the Lincoln lesson if not
part of the tour you mean I didn't have
to be listening to all that discount
Tiki Barber would never let anything
happen to you obvious foreshadowing
dialog cliche oh snap the x-men got
caught up in an Improv Everywhere
performance what do you need just your
authorization for special operation
Blackrock we developed the technology
that built his plastic prison so plastic
then this is the last time we see
senator Kelly I wonder if anyone else
will miss him once mystique stops
beating him for a few weeks and probably
just my long-lost twin brother the less
questions I asked the better no one
stores their soda in the pantry unless
they like it warm or happen to have a
script requiring the Iceman even to do
something cute with his powers thanks
but now and then every mother needs to
get away without her the babies are
helpless conveniently timed nature
program foreshadowing cliche admit it
you rooted for evil to win there that's
a nifty trick this helicopter pulled
opening the doors with wind I guess I
admit Wolverines claws are pretty badass
but I think they would be awful at
starting cars damn don't let striker
know the mutants one weakness is in sync
it's cerebro's gatekeepers been fooled
twice now don't you think it might be
time to go with the password or secret
question didn't magneto tell Stryker
everything about cerebro when you break
it down cerebro is a pretty simple
machine all you need is that all this
and that
what exactly was a stumbling block to
building his own see even hot girls need
a roofie a guy for a sure thing now and
again this dudes underwear you'll have
to forgive Iceman True Blood wasn't for
another five years
I wish I had that cliche too much iron
too much iron in your blood enough to
make these three iron balls but not
enough to be detected by the metal
detector that's it's cheap job
description if professor X's helmet is
keeping him from using his telepathy
then how is Jason's telepathy getting
past the helmet this is why you bring
your spinning top or loaded die with you
at all times
how does magneto know that they would
fly here how long has he been camping in
these woods with mystique waiting for a
plane to fly overhead wait a minute
how would strike or even know where to
find cerebro in the first place didn't
she have an accident in the last movie
or at least some of the time girls flirt
with the dangerous guy Logan don't take
him home I know several bars and pubs
that would disagree with you it's in
vain not stained this guy's all the time
we shouldn't have to you know mystique
is right you shouldn't have to be a
closet mutant but mistakes problems are
like the problems of really cook and
she's all that as if no one would ever
want to be her friend or want to have
sex with her mystique is sexier is her
blue self than 99% of the human
population Wolverine can smell that it
was mystique in the first movie but his
penis overwhelms his nose in the sequel
and it's only the scars that give it
away holy shit is epic and who played
Cameron in Dead Poets Society I still
want to punch that movie establishes
that the two people fighting or equally
matched which means that some sort of
total bullet is gonna have to happen for
one of them die see why is there an
illusion of a little girl here now when
magneto and mystique came in before it
was completely normal did they instruct
Jason to create an illusion while also
trying to perform the very difficult
task of controlling Xavier's mind and
killing all the humans
yeah this guy what an asshole who gives
us that you came here in a jet remember
it might be understandable for him to
forget but everyone including storm
doesn't remember they came here in a jet
like what was the plan anyway fly off in
the helicopter and leave rogue and
Iceman to die as they sat dutifully
waiting in the jet or fly off and
helicopter to go to the jet wasting all
that time on a short trip when the jet
is like a hundred yards away what how
would a rogue know when the perfect time
is to start flying this thing how did
she even get it in the air cool scene
but what mutation movie ends with the
exact same narration from the beginning
of the first movie that was that back
there
strike
his name is straightening Ostreicher
these lights represent every living
person on the planet
you took my sonar concept and applied it
to every phone in the city half the city
feeding you saw now you can image all of
nothing this is wrong